as we enter into 1917
the united states has been able to
maintain its neutrality in world war one
in fact president wilson has just won a
re-election based on the platform that
he kept us out of war
and to a large degree he was able to
keep the us out of war because the
german empire had pulled back from its
unrestricted submarine warfare after the
sinking of the lusitania and how angered
america had gotten they said okay we're
not going to attack passenger vessels
anymore we're only going to attack
things that are definitely british
non-passenger vessels but as we go into
january of 1917
the british blockade on the central
powers were having was having its effect
and the central powers were getting
desperate in particular germany and so
they're eager to essentially
do the same to the british once again go
with the unrestricted submarine warfare
but the germans knew that if they were
to go back to this that it's likely that
the u.s would enter the war on the side
of the allies so knowing that that was
likely to happen they said well how
could we slow the us down and the
thinking was well maybe we could somehow
enlist the help of mexico which at the
time was not on the best terms with the
united states
and so arthur zimmerman
arthur zimmerman who was the german
foreign secretary the equivalent of the
united states secretary of state the
foreign minister arthur zimmerman sends
an encoded telegram
to
the mexicans and it's encoded especially
because it has to go over lines that are
controlled by the americans and in it he
appro he actually proposes an alliance
to slow the americans down
so this is what he wrote so this is the
encoded telegram and then it was
actually intercepted by british
intelligence and decoded and then shared
with the americans and then that was
also then made public to to the american
public and so this is why it's
fascinating to actually read the stuff
this is january 1917.
this is the germans talking to the
mexicans
we intend to begin on the first of
february unrestricted submarine warfare
we shall endeavor in spite of this to
keep the united states of america
neutral
in the event of this not succeeding we
make mexico a proposal of alliance on
the following basis
make war together make peace together
generous financial support and an
understanding on our part that mexico is
to re-conquer the lost territories the
lost territory in texas new mexico and
arizona this settlement or the
settlement in detail is left to you you
will inform the president they're
talking about the president of mexico of
the above most secretly as soon as the
outbreak of war with the united states
with the united states of america is
certain and add the suggestion that he
should on his own initiative invite
japan to immediate adherence and at the
same time mediate between japan and
ourselves please call the president's
attention to the fact that the ruthless
employment of our submarines now offers
the prospect of compelling england in a
few months to make peace signed
zimmerman
now the mexicans when they read this
they really didn't take it too seriously
they didn't think that they could
seriously engage the us in a war they
could seriously take back or occupy
these territories so they didn't really
think much of it the real effect of this
telegram was to really was to make the
american public angry they were going to
go back into the unrestricted submarine
warfare and the germans themselves talk
about ruthless
ruthless employment of our submarines so
when people talk about what were the
causes what brought the us into war the
ones that are typically cited are the
unrestricted submarine warfare the
sinking of the lusitania the zimmerman
telegram that was trying to get mexico
to somehow get into a war with the u.s
and reclaim these territories and as
we'll see
a few months after this the us actually
does declare war on germany and enter
into world war one